alright hey everybody I'm backstage with
one of gqueues most influential nerds of
2014 the title is that accomplished it's
a real title I just learned of it today
and who I think they're running out of
lists to make know you're very
influential birds who would have fought
that won't ever be a category who would
have thought that GQ would take that on
but it's so exciting to have you here
because you just finished cosmos yeah
yeah well he nominates he'll recover it
Stefan 12 amine Armand everything it was
proposed to be nominated for it got a
nomination for we're all very excited
about it I'm excited about it I just got
caught up on the series and thanks
seriously well I was all that people are
like we've never been on time for
anything no I was gonna say a little bit
of a spoiler alert but everybody should
have been caught up by now because if
I've done it you know you can at the end
of the series you leave the helm of the
spaceship of the imagination what are
you doing leaving the helm this isn't
like a Italian cruise ship what's gonna
happen what's because it's not my ship
our ship
it's your ship thank you the viewer oh
yeah
it's a gift of the production to the
viewer so that you can explore the
cosmos at your will will we see somebody
else on TV get into that seat
I mean someone other than me I'm a
second season kind of effort there's a
lot of talk about second season yeah but
I don't want to think of it as well we
just did a TV series now let's do next
year it's like give it room to breathe
and to be digested into our souls of
curiosity the original cosmos 34 years
ago they didn't just do another season
right after that that thing was had an
epic scope and mission statement and
when that's how you're making your
television
you can't just rattle that off every
seat but it's that but you got people
hooked on the science now I know and we
want more of it you can't just cut us
off cold turkey
so are you saying that's all there is to
know about the universe ask me again in
a year okay maybe I would have recovered
by then maybe I'll be back from the
Bahamas by then as I'm trying to regain
my energy level that's quiet it was
quite a production effort 70 locations
seven countries 13 episode we're all
over the places in forests and in
Abbey's and churches and in fields at
Newton's birthplace and the funny thing
is this I never talked haven't tell
anybody
two of the locations were green-screen
one of them was correct just like the
moon landing so when was it and the
other believe it or not was lower
Manhattan really two places you don't
want to be no I live hell over man
nobody been easy to weed across the
Brooklyn Bridge and do the scene yeah
but to set up there and the time given
how many minutes of actual airtime that
represented we just we got good plates
of the horizon of the cityscape and then
they just grafted me into the floor
when you hear a year ago you're just go
well this was not here blank wall last
exactly I love what you did with the
place yeah but when you were here last
time you're just gearing up to do the
space show at the Hayden Planetarium oh
yes now it's now open oh it's great
oh man it's dark Matt it's called the
dark universe and it's all about dark
matter dark energy the discovery of it
how much of the universe we have no clue
what's going on and it was audacious
because the show is about what we don't
know right rather than what we do this
is the space show it's the Hayden
Planetarium that's my day job but I'm
not on TV oh you're talking about what
you guys actually work okay and you're
still doing start talk live start talks
dark talk and start talk live when it's
in a theater right but otherwise it's in
studio yes star talk is a radio show and
podcast we're on the host you can all
its dropped on you by Neil deGrasse
Tyson any time you cracked on your ass
no so that it's in the it's inverted an
inverted model of what the normal
science radio show would be normally
there's a journalist interviewing a
scientist typically but in this case I'm
the host and I'm the scientist and my
guest is hardly ever a scientist someone
Hughes from pop culture then we talk
about how science has impacted that
person's livelihood thank you and so
it's science as it has manifested in our
lives now I like stars and I don't who
doesn't if I were to buy a telescope to
look at stars what would you recommend
as somebody who's who's into that sort
of thing are we talking it's way more
complicated because it's teletran no no
it's how much it's how much money do you
have and how big is your backyard how
dark are your skies will you be
transporting it will you not are you
tech savvy are you not and all of these
factors come in and it's as you answer
each one of those questions the field
narrows and then you land on the right
telescope for you
so it's like saying there is a right
telescope for everyone
yes oh yeah but depending on your needs
yeah yeah depending your needs and your
budget but it's like saying oh what car
should I buy well what do you need how
many kids do you have well it's those
kinds of questions
with telescopes isn't what are you what
are you peeping into these days oh do
you know that New York City has the hunt
I read this I haven't verified it but
I've read it that's gotta be just gotta
be true but I didn't read it on the
Internet so there has a higher chance of
it being true that New York City has the
highest per capita ownership of
telescopes yeah so what the hell are
they looking at probably the neighbors
yeah what heavenly bodies are they
accidentally poking in on so on cloudy
nights I make sure my curtains are
closed good coffee on a clear night the
sky can distract from peeping toms I
understand yeah it makes sense
dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson thank you so
much thanks for having back to the show
used to be an annual thing I like it
keep it up all right
thank you see you next year